Bruce let me start with UCLA firing Jim
Mora why now well if you hope to get
into Chip Kelly sweepstakes you're gonna
make a big swing at him and I think they
knew Florida had already had some had
gotten some traction there with chip and
this is really the big fish out there in
this coaching coaching cycle I mean
talking about a guy who went forty six
and seven and four years at Oregon
arguably the most innovative offensive
mind in all of football and he's worked
in the pac-12 had a lot of success here
so I think that was that's the chance to
say hey what's the one thing we can do
that can really put a real scare into
our archrival USC and that's go get Chip
Kelly do you think it felt like it was a
fait accompli that more was going to be
fired at the end of the year but if UCLA
beats USC they're not firing Jim Mora
are they if this same scenario presents
itself that Florida is you know up on
Chip Kelly's doorstep in New Hampshire
yeah I think that's very hard to do you
fire him after he beats the archrival
and by the way he'd beaten him three
years and you know in his first three
years there so I think that's that's a
hard sell then maybe you look at it okay
well going forward he's got it changes
defensive staff because they've been
awful you know on the defensive side of
the ball or make some adjustments there
but in this case again this is such a
big move for them to make and we're
talking about a school that doesn't
really throw around that much money
they're gonna have to pay amyl gym more
they have to pay him over 12 million
dollars the other big plus with Chip
Kelly here as you're getting a such a
big value coach if you can get him where
he's already getting paid so much money
by the San Francisco 49ers that it
mitigates a lot of a lot of the costs
that it would come on on to you on the
front end of it how does Florida go to
Chip Kelly's house in New Hampshire and
not come back with Chip Kelly you know
Dan I was told this by a source that
they were not expected it was never part
of the plan that he was gonna be on the
plane coming back you know this wasn't
the first meeting that they had
with with Kelly but you know I think he
wants to do things he's not gonna this
is gonna be this his last you know big
move part of his career and I think he
wants to really get this sorted out a
hundred percent in his head before he
before he makes his decision it's going
to be on his time and so I think he
wants to be a hundred percent on it and
look I think he knows Florida is a great
job you know you have a huge huge
recruiting pool you have good resources
you have a program that's won national
titles with multiple coaches the the
question is is it the most comfortable
fit for him you know I think there's
some other big SEC jobs and quite
honestly I don't think Chip Kelly would
want any part of either because of the
leadership you know on top of them that
he's not he wouldn't be comfortable with
or just the fishbowl quality of it
Florida doesn't have as much of that
fishbowl quality and from everything I
had heard coming out of this meeting
that both sides felt it went very well
hmm talking to Bruce Pelton Feldman from
Fox Sports and Sports Illustrated their
college football insider what about
Scott frost is a wild card in Florida I
know that there's the possibility of him
going back to his alma mater Nebraska
but he's done a great job at Central
Florida knows the area realizes how much
talent is down there could you see Scott
frost going to Florida if they don't get
Chip Kelly
I could I mean look keep in mind Florida
has been dismal on offense for a long
time it's been about eight years and
they never liked a seven or eight year
stretch where they've ranked about 85th
or worse and it's been much worse than
that and Scott frost Chip Kelly disciple
as you said he took over a program that
was awful at UCF they had won zero games
and they were basically dead last in the
whole country in offense and now they're
number one in the country in offense so
you know if you don't get Chip Kelly the
one question with with Scott frost and I
think it's certainly relevant with with
the UF is you have a guy who's only been
a head coach for less than two years
he's done exceptionally well but when
you're at Florida you know that when
it's gone wrong on the on the coaching
fires it went wrong when they brought in
Lanza he had never really never been a
head coach it did not go well with Will
Muschamp he had never been a head coach
and it didn't you know and there was
some good and some bad but just on the
handling the big stage did not work out
for Jim McElwain and he didn't have a
ton of head coaching experience
give me the what is real the reality of
Tennessee opening who they can get ya
because Jon Gruden it feels like it's
sort of floating out there and you know
in rumor land can they land Johnny I
think it's wishful I think it's very
wishful thinking from from you know big
Tennessee boosters and people you know
kind of a you know covering the team you
know because it's a it's a hot sexy
story with jump with Jon Gruden I mean
the reality with Jon Gruden is he is
making a fortune now for you know doing
Monday Night Football and all the
endorsements he has attached to it he's
making more than almost any coach in the
country is now so it's not like he's
gonna look at the money and go whoo I
gotta jump into that and he knows that
how much work there would be to be a
college head coach it's different than
being an NFL head coach recruiting is is
24/7 365 you know you're in the middle
of the summer and some kid texture cuz
he's in town and he wants to take an
unofficial visit and all the other
headaches that come with being a head
coach then I just think that you know
he's never even been a college head
coach he hasn't worked in college for
almost 30 years so I think Jon Gordon
likes the attention that will come with
it but I think he probably has some fun
with it and it's kicked into into high
gear I think a more viable option for
them is if you can get Dan Mullen from
Mississippi State he knows the SEC he's
done a really good job developing
quarterbacks you know he's got it done
it getting gonna get paid four point
five million dollars in Starkville I
think Tennessee could take him up six
point five there you have a better
chance to win a national title in
Knoxville you know in the SEC East thing
you do in Starkville in the SEC West
which is the toughest job to win at the
questions gonna be does he really want
to leave
I think the situation he has now because
he wins the average is about eight wins
in his over his last five years that's
good in Starkville they'll love you
there if you do that in Knoxville you
won't be there five years they'll get
they'll get tired and run you're out I
think he I think he knows he knows that
part of it I could see Gruden coming
back for one job and it might shock
everybody but that would be the Raiders
but uh you know we'll keep an eye on he
keeps keeping his name out there's his
agent is a Baker Mayfield with what
happened on the sidelines against Kansas
and how this affects Heisman voters if
it does you know it doesn't affect it
dramatically no I don't think so I think
there'll be a handful of Heisman voters
who will who will say you know what I'm
taking him off my ballot I'm very
uncomfortable with that you know look
it's the third time Baker's had to
apologize for something I don't I don't
you know
ding him for the planning the flag in
Columbus I mean I think that was kind of
it's just a kind of a silly story this
one I get it it's a bad look for him he
embarrassed that the embarrassed
Oklahoma embarrassed himself you know
he's apologized for it when you look at
what he's done over the course of this
year he is by far and away the top guy
before the Heisman I mean he has put
that program on his back without without
Baker Mayfield with a pretty average
defense that Oklahoma team is right now
probably has seven wins with him they
are a legit national title threat and I
think he's the most outstanding player
and right now he's far and away my
number one guy and you know it's a
talking point this today what he did and
you know like hopefully for his sake
there's not gonna be more of that but
you never know I mean he's an emotional
guy and he seems to get swept up in a
lot of it and that's just I think if you
take him you know that you're gonna get
some of that with him that's he he has a
big edge to him that's part of the
reason why I thinks he's played so well
and you know they gotta manage it better
Bruce thanks for joining us we
appreciate it already pleasure Dan
thanks for Adam and that's Bruce Feldman
Fox Sports college football insider for
more Dan Patrick show to the
channel 239 on Direct TV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]